[Music]
[Applause]
Reggie Miller Hall of Famer you'll be on
the call tonight it's the Sixers and the
Celtics tip off 7 30 Eastern on TNT also
doing game two of that series Wednesday
night also on TNT reg I didn't realize
this we were talking about Steph Curry
getting 50 with one turnover
Reggie in 1992 against the Hornets had
57 with zero turnovers zero well there's
a reason for that okay
I wasn't going to pass it today
[Laughter]
did you not have any assist either
I think I may have had eight assists
okay so I I was giving up the rock but
on a night like that when you're feeling
it like that
you uh you want that orange in your hand
you want it in your hand okay Sacramento
knows who's getting the ball they double
teamed it they did everything that
you're supposed to do with Steph Curry
why didn't any of this work
because Stephen Curry is superhuman if
you look at his stat line first of all
what's more impressive which no one is
talking about
the dude the dude took 38 field goal
attempts Theodore he was 20 for 38. 38
field golden Temps
you don't understand how great of shape
you have to be in to sustain that yeah
and you could double triple team them
all you want in today's game where
there's freedom of movement and you
can't hold clutch trip elbow
you're gonna have nights like this and
in a game seven I don't care if it was
on the road or at home against the team
with very little to no experience other
than her head coach who has won
championships with the team that he was
going against
um you kind of figured it would be this
type of outcome Steve Kerr mentioned
Steph Curry in the same sentence with
Michael Jordan
yep I can see it
uh again I don't want people flooding my
Twitter inbox but you got to look at the
historical context and
Michael did everything in the air Air
Jordan he revolutionized the game he
changed the way we thought the baggy
shorts the black socks the shoes
obviously the Air Jordans
Stephen Curry has taken shooting in the
art form of it and moving without the
ball to a different level
and every you know because I have a
nine-year-old and I go to all these you
know these games the first thing kids do
they know they can't dunk and fly like
Michael Jordan but they all believe they
can shoot like Stephen Curry and that's
the first thing they do is start
hoisting up threes to try and be like
their hero Stephen Curry so you have
Heroes to most in Michael Jordan and you
have a lot of Heroes in Stephen Curry I
I see the comparison
but who's had a bigger impact on the
sport it's Michael Jordan no from
playing
they
well here's here's the thing I'll take
that back I will say Stephen Curry for
this reason he's playing in the age of
social media
there wasn't that when Michael Jordan
played you had to actually watch the
games there wasn't uh you go back on
your phone and replay
you know Stephen Curry's in the age the
digital age so we have access to
Instagram Tick Tock uh Twitter and we
see the highlights and the plays and you
know ESPN 360 every talk show
a lot of that was just beginning with
Michael Jordan yeah and it wasn't around
so I would say Stephen Curry has had the
bigger Global impact I think Michael
Jordan's really now more so famous for
the shoes
he is and was
but and it shouldn't have taken this
game but I'm going to use this game this
is springboard into when Steph is all
said and done how does he get into the
top 10 players of all time
I think he may be in there I think his
late you know everyone's saying this was
a legacy game for Stephen Curry to me I
think his legacy game was in the finals
last year versus Boston in that closeout
win on the road in Boston to me that was
his legacy game because he did it
without I mean he won one without KD the
first one then he won two with Katie and
everyone's like okay well they needed KD
to win those championships and he was
never a Finals MVP and that was a finals
MVP series closeout game to me that was
his legacy game to me he was just it was
time to put the kids to bed to me that
was that kind of statement all right I'm
done messing with my food these kids are
annoying me yes they're entertaining
they're hot they're they're an
up-and-coming team but it's time to put
the kids to bed and then it was that
type of game and curry made it he just
wanted to put a statement on putting the
kids to bed all right so you have Jordan
LeBron
Kareem Kareem Kobe Tim Duncan Tim Duncan
oh
Tim Duncan would be a absolutely in the
top ten
um
Bill Russell Bill Russell you got Wilt
in there
I want to think about Shaq I may go with
Shaq over will okay
how many do I am I up to now
you know what I think you almost have to
take Russell and Wilt out of this
it's a different it's a it's a different
game
yeah but
I I got a value those championships okay
I do all right so Duncan is does bird
make the top ten oh man
oh Magic imagine magic magic magic
uh I gotta put bird slash magic or magic
slash Bird that's gonna be one yeah can
they be one yeah okay like I'm gonna
have to do that for what they meant to
the game I think I'm gonna do magic
slash bird bird thank you okay magic
slash bird Michael but I might give
Michael two spots man
like Mike's running too running two
you're right okay so Shaq
um Tim Duncan
magic bird MJ
Curry
is Durant in there
not on this list I think we're running
out of spots aren't we outside looking
in he's on the outside looking in I I
think if he wins what if he wins this
year what if he wins this year and it's
finals MVP yeah you might have to think
about him because that would be three
finals MVPs yeah
okay he'd have to win one more to get
into consideration for the time into
consideration correct but you have Steph
Curry in the top ten I have curry in the
top ten because he also changed the way
we perceived shooting
okay
he's the greatest shooter the game has
ever seen
how do the Lakers deal with him
attention to detail and I don't I'm not
quite sure they can follow those habits
for a seven game series you you have to
follow the game plan but in an amazing
reg this many years in
we there there's there's a scouting
report on Steph but nobody has stopped
him he's not the fastest guy the
strongest guy tallest guy can't jump
isn't that amazing
it's amazing it but it goes to show you
um Stephen Curry Rip Hamilton Ray Allen
all three of those guys what do they
have in common non-stop in motion you
can't you can't guard which you can't
stop or hold they're constantly in
motion yeah they're they're the most fit
basketball players I played against so
if you are constantly moving and you are
a great shooter and you can handle and
you can pass
you have so many things at your disposal
Theodore
it's just you know like his biggest
opponent is time
I mean it's it's him versus time or his
body and here's the thing I'm 57 and I
can still shoot oh I know that's not
that's not going to diminish with him
foot speed will come and go that that'll
probably start to slow down but as long
as he can
still shoot which you will be able to do
when he's 40 45 he can play as long as
he wants because some in today's game
you need Shooters you need people that
can space the floor he'll always have a
job yeah he could he could eventually
have the role that his dad had when his
dad played because Dell was off the ball
and basically a you know a spot-up
shooter
and if you get a traditional point guard
in there and he could just play shooting
guard and come off screens and people
forget how great of a passer he is as
well I know they think about the threes
in the shooting but he's a great passer
and he can handle the basketball I mean
look that last play when he got his 50th
point and he's Curly Neal dribbling
through everyone and then the layup
um just remarkable he's Reggie Miller
the Hall of Famer he'll be on the call
tonight Sixers and the Celtics uh it
feels like the Lakers will win game one
against Golden State for some reason uh
I it could happen I don't know I don't
know why and I don't know like sometimes
you're drained after a series and
sometimes you're energized after a
series I'm not sure what Golden State
will be I see your point but I think
what golden state has gone for for them
is coming off of game seven where
they've been locked in it's not a huge
turnaround to start game one but I will
say what the Lakers have in their favor
and this dates back all the way to the
Anthony Davis New Orlean Pelicans days
they had no answer for him when he was
with the Pelicans facing Golden State in
the first round he dominated them
they will go as far as Anthony Davis
will take him the greatest LeBron is and
has been and will always be we mentioned
one of the top ten he's probably in the
top five LeBron James
the Lakers want to get to the Conference
Finals and win a championship it's all
going to be on Anthony Davis shoulders
and he has dominated over the years
Golden State because they're a smaller
team and I give come on Looney credit
he's done a great job but Anthony Davis
is a different Beast it depends on which
Anthony Davis is going to show up in
this series if it's the dominant one
that we saw in the last two games of
that Memphis Series this is going to be
a long series for Golden State but if
he's passive
again LeBron is great don't get me wrong
and he'll have his moments but it's got
to be Anthony Davis fingerprints all
over the series if not I know what I'm
going to get out of Step clay Draymond
and Jordan pool I know what I'm going to
get and that's going to be a fun series
I just think golden state has too many
offensive weapons for the Lakers
what advice would you give Dylan Brooks
yeah
uh
uh face the media
what I was disappointed about that and
this is coming from a guy who is very
loquacious and talked a lot right
Theodore you know me very well but when
it's time to face the music you gotta
get in front of the camera you can't be
walking out if you're going to talk all
that noise about LeBron being old
you know I give job credit he owned up
to it he said it you know I'm good in
the west there's no one in the west and
he you know he owned it
if you're going to say all that stuff
either joke about it but you can't run
from it I'm tired of all the Talking
from the Grizzlies and I'm a talker it's
time for some action it's time it was
time for some action and y'all later a
so own it own it stop right stop stop
hiding from it face it
what chances do you give the Sixers
given the fact that uh no MB tonight
in tonight's game we're in the series in
the series series in general even if he
is healthy
he was healthy
they would have an absolute if you look
at the numbers I mean he has dominated
when healthy but him being hurt not
knowing what kind of shape he is when he
does come back if he does come back for
game two or the rest of the series uh
this is all about the Celtics and after
what we saw with Milwaukee going down uh
against the Heat now they're the overall
best record left in these playoffs I
think if you're Boston there's got to be
a sense of urgency that this has to be a
year because it's wide open and if
embiid is not 100 percent
um and they struggled against Atlanta
people thought that was going to be
asleep and they really struggled against
the Hawks maybe it was a wake-up call
they were thinking past Atlanta gearing
up for this I think they'll be locked
and loaded and ready to go tonight
the garden had the atmosphere
they had it they had everything that you
would I mean I know Julius Randle wasn't
there but you had the celebrities were
there the atmosphere Patrick Ewing comes
back spikes in the building
but they forgot about one thing winning
Jimmy
[Music]
with him and his little turned ankle
let's see how he comes
bounces back from that as well so that's
going to be a long series I'm not
worried
people in New York stop it's not that
dramatic it's only one game one game
relax just relax one day
you gotta win those games I know you
gotta know when the juice is there
you're right you're right but it's only
one game aside from Spike Lee did you
interact with anybody else in New York
no Spike pretty much took up most of my
time in that building and roughly so
because he's front and center he's the
face of the Knicks I love him uh we're
at a better
place now in our relationship uh we're
much more friendlier when we see one
another he's a good dude but in those
moments
and deep down in my belly look I'll
always have a disdain for the New York
Knicks there was that's just how I am
but I respect him I respect John Starks
because you know why the dude fought and
he would fall down and come back and be
like is that all you got I respect dudes
like that
but did you want to fight Spike Lee
no
any fan
well no he was in front now the dudes on
their team Oakley and well you didn't
want to fight Oakley I didn't want to
fight him I would get my Davis voice to
fight him are you crazy I'm fighting
Charles Oakley why was it why did Oakley
scare everybody in the NBA oh okay that
dude was real man like what do you mean
one of the guys you you hated to play
against but you wish he was on your 14.
but okay so he wasn't a great player but
everybody is like scared of him
set the best screens was a above average
to pretty good rebounder yeah but when
see there's there's no more enforcers in
the NBA game there's no more there's no
buck Williams my Davis boys uh
you know Charles Oakley there's there's
no longer that there's no more role for
that because you got to be skilled that
but have that position
and he played it perfectly Bill Lambert
played it perfectly you know Rick Mahorn
those guys were perfect in their roles
okay let's say you passed away first
does Spike Lee speak at your funeral
uh
I hope so would you speak yes I would
yes I would but I think you got a Heckle
him because he he should Heckle you if
if
you should show up in full uniform if
you live longer than Spike and and you
know you have to Heckle him I if I would
come I would come to his funeral dressed
in all orange and blue skies like he
would like I would be I like Nick colors
at his whoa and his way breaking news
okay all right just like he better be in
blue and gold okay all right you
probably didn't think you were getting
that question today no I didn't now you
got me worried about you know the
afterlife here don't put it in the
universe oh my goodness why are you
jinxing us do you know who your
pallbearers are going to be I do not
nor do I care because if it's time for
the Lord to bring me home it's time
it is time well I got five guys here and
that leaves one opening can I can I oh
well better be on yours I better be one
of your balls you're gonna be one of
mine you better be I'm asking you right
now do you want to be one of my I want
you to be one of my all right I'll be
I'll be a polder all right and I'm gonna
be one of yours okay
all right trying to think who I think
Bryant Gumbel
was picking somebody told me he picked
his pallbearers
really yeah well
I got I mean it's a little morbid but
then if you go you know what it'd be
nice if I had so you have your dad Nets
and me so you're set now no no I'm not
having my dad had to be pallbear why not
no no maybe one maybe one
which one
do I have fritzy I mean fritzy's got
guns I mean he's got some big arms
I don't know it doesn't matter the guns
because you got five other guys holding
it up so don't go by the physical
stature go by who you can who's been in
your corner oh who's been in my corner
whoa and I gotta get six guys
well you got to pick one dance so out of
them you know you already have two so
you have me I got you one dinette now we
need four other guys or or girls okay
that's that could be true yeah shorties
[Music]
well I don't know you know it's
uh I can see Keith being one yeah so now
we have three not only yeah
we need three more we're filling out the
roster
would you have any like Mark Jackson is
your brother Jackson would be one okay
Not only would he be a pallbearer but he
would give the eulogy
uh would Rick Smits want to be a
pallbearer let me see who else would be
one with Shaq Cheryl Dean oh yeah so
your sister all right so that's what am
I up to now four four
I'm up to four see I'm ahead of you what
about Jordan what if you asked Michael
Jordan to be a Paul yeah please
you're right he would Heckle you
did you ever think about wearing Air
Jordans when you played I did where I
was part of the Jordan brand
I did wear Jordans and it pained me well
that no it no I was wearing Jordans
against Jordan getting done by Jordan
does that make sense I wasn't wearing
Jordans against Michael Jordan getting
done by Michael Jordan did he that has
to be the ultimate trash talk like dude
you're wearing my shoes I own you
well I wouldn't go that far well no but
if I'm Jordan I would have said I own
you man you're wearing my shoes
he's probably saying yeah I'm sure I'm
putting money in his pocket you're right
uh have fun tonight reg I appreciate it
I love y'all know which one
it's one gialo wishes
and uh he'll be on the call tonight with
the Celtics and the Sixers that'll be on
TNT 7 30 Eastern back after this